las pandémicas llevan al límite al
gobierno británico la emisora itv reveló
una invitación de martín reynolds
secretario privado del primer ministro
boris johnson a una reunión de más de
100 personas cargadas de alcohol en
downing street- del 20 de mayo de 2020
el parlamento pidió la comparecencia de
johnson para que reconociera o negara su
asistencia pero el gobierno envió un
funcionario de bajo perfil
me disculpo no sin reservas por el
malestar que han causado estas
acusaciones el primer ministro ha pedido
que se lleve a cabo una investigación
la fiesta se celebró cuando el país
vivía fuertes restricciones con escuelas
cerradas y sin posibilidad de despedirse
de familiares víctimas de kobe 19 el
mismo día de la reunión el secretario de
cultura había hecho el siguiente
recordatorio terminado a encontrar
formas creativas y sin multitudes de
navegar por el coronavirus es el mayor
desafío para nuestros sectores de
recreación y ocio en este momento se
suena una alta funcionaria del gobierno
su grey con forma de mano dura está
investigando cinco fiestas en
departamentos gubernamentales
la policía ha pedido información para
iniciar una investigación
el partido laborista pide
responsabilidades y upson creo que su
ausencia lo dice todo igual que su
sonrisa ante los medios de comunicación
el público ya ha sacado sus propias
conclusiones puede huir pero no puede
esconderse lee kang
no es la primera crisis de boris johnson
por las fiestas en diciembre se conoció
que en las navidades de 2020 en downing
street también se saltaron las
restricciones detrás de las revelaciones
estaría dominique cummings antiguo
asesor que dejó el cargo por enfrentarse
con la actual esposa de boris johnson
[Aplausos]